hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
that's it
that's it pack it up strong guys
pack it the [ __ ] up strong guys dude i
want to start i should start somber man
the strong guys had their days
they had their day
the new merch is out
sport it
we [ __ ] with body weight we [ __ ] with
kettlebells
we do all sorts of jumps it's crazy
these strong guys are out there breaking
look i don't i'm not in the business of
breaking hearts but strong guys
i had to do what i had to do and i'm so
sorry strong guys
i'm sorry to break your heart strong
guys but your boys fancy with the
kettlebells okay new merch it's up there
you go sorry strong guys killing it and
we killed it we didn't mean to kill it
but it just happened it just so happens
we killed it
trying to not use
uh plastic bottles so go to
crystallia.com
and go ahead and break all the strong
guys hearts when you're out in public
when you're at the gym you get to your
gym you got this [ __ ] nice hoodie
look at that mustard look at that
mustard orange yellow who could forget
those beautiful colors if you see these
colors once you've seen them a million
times after that in your head they are
seared into your head they are
absolutely that orange it's a it's
basically a new color i mean i thought
we saw all the colors right
red and blue they make purple and uh
blue and green they make green or some
[ __ ] whatever all of them together mick
brown there's like a bunch of different
colors i've never seen this orange it's
burnt and we got the black dude i'm so
sorry to break your heart strong guys
it's not my problem go mend your hearts
i work out i go delicious on it dude
i go delicious at the gym but it's at
home i'm sorry strong guys
you know what i mean you're doing it at
the [ __ ] place with all the
memberships dude strong guys i'm in my
garage getting delicious with it i'm
sorry to break your heart dude
you figured that out two years will be
better
um yeah dude so it's it man that's it
and we're doing it and we're [ __ ]
moving up
we [ __ ] uh sold out sold out sold out
so doubt duck in one time we sold out
the [ __ ] uh
shits and it's back and we got the life
rip [ __ ] back anyway enough of the merch
stuff let's get it out the way you know
what i mean i had to uh had to do that
and it's all good it's all good my baby
dude we're chilling man
hello it's november
and um
yes dude yes yes it's november it is
november 4th my christmas tree is up and
i [ __ ] and it shouldn't be
dude it shouldn't be yes my christmas
tree's up do i like it no
is it okay sure does it make calvin
happy yes because of sparkly lights does
it make kristin happy yes because it's
her favorite time of the year and it
gets longer every year pretty soon
christmas is just going to be 10 months
and there's going to be two months of
non-christmas and does it keep moving up
yes is it like this podcast and does it
keep moving up yes it does dude
it does and it's too much christmas
going on now for the whole year after
uh halloween
after you hear oh
for the last time in the year kristen
goes like this
and that's when the christmas lights
turn on i say what about thanksgiving
and she says what's thanksgiving that's
the kind of humor she does i appreciate
it it's funny but i'm simmering
but i'm simmering because guess what i
love christmas and matter of fact
christmas is my favorite part of the
year it's my favorite day of the year
christmas eve and christmas are great
but when you prolong it what's that dude
that deludes christmas doesn't it
but i guess not man them hallmark movies
are playing she's got that [ __ ] those
deep cuts too man she's got deep cuts
i mean her cuts go so deep dude she's
playing that [ __ ] uh rudolph the
red-nosed one where the people are all
choppy and claymation
you know what i'm talking about
calvin looks at santa now already and he
goes
and i'm like all right well that's real
cute but don't tug on my heartstrings
dude when i'm trying to be simmering i'm
simmering you're trying to tug my heart
strings
who's side john calvin and um so yeah so
she put it up and she did it too soon
and it's all good man what do you got to
do what do you what do i what am i gonna
do no
she drags that tree in no she asked for
help she wanted to put [ __ ] uh um
what do you call them gnomes or elves
flying up on the ceiling and i'm just
like that's where i'm gonna draw the
line but guess what the gnomes will
[ __ ] be up soon i guarantee it do it
and i guarantee it
the gnomes will be up soon and that's
when the [ __ ] men's warehouse guy
comes in and says i guarantee it
um because that's what's going to happen
for sure i say don't put the gnomes up
there they're scary calvin thinks
they're scary he goes like this
whatever he sees the gnomes or elves
whatever they are
uh i think they're elves what is a gnome
what is an elf i don't know is it bad to
[ __ ] mix up gnomes with elves anyway
um
it's all good dude so we're ready for
christmas already and we put up a video
we're get we're gonna sh we shot a
little video for the christmas [ __ ] it's
gonna be on more crystallia check out
that youtube page more crystalia um and
we're gonna put them out we put it out
my new show with chris comes out every
episode uh every every episode is monday
on uh on on youtube anyway um
so yeah christmas is nice but let's not
talk about it because i don't want to
[ __ ] have to put that on you do you
understand what what a good of a guy i
am
so [ __ ] persian said that so persian
what a good of a guy i am dude do you
understand how good of a guy i am that i
am living through this
too
early christmas and i'm gonna stop this
from getting out of hand on the podcast
i'm not gonna talk to you about the
christmas even though i've been talking
about for five minutes i'm gonna stop
right now because i don't wanna subject
you guys to that and that's how much
that's how much i respect the people
that listen to this podcast okay now you
know your book keeps it super
disrespectful right
but i keep it super disrespectful and
that's what makes it respectful right
because i'm being me and you get a
little slice of me right
okay and that's fine
and that's great but i would never stoop
solo as to subjected to christmas too
early now here what we're gonna do
because we're gonna have a christmas
episode later we'll do that but that's
fine but um
but yeah so
um
so instead of that let's talk about this
i was out today and um i was getting uh
no as a matter of fact i was waiting in
line to get a
a piece of food i was trying to get it
something to eat it was a i don't know
probably something like a protein bowl
because of how [ __ ] ridiculously
[ __ ] stacked i am and uh yeah dude i
eat bread sometimes but usually just
late at night and then the day i keep it
really [ __ ] lean i'm practically a
trout and so i [ __ ]
so i i was waiting in line for the
[ __ ] um for the protein bowl or
something like that i don't know maybe
they were just handing me a [ __ ]
whole salmon i can't even remember but i
keep it so lean dude
and so uh i can't remember what he was
giving me maybe just a [ __ ] head of
lettuce i can't remember but dude i was
keeping it so lean it was ridiculous and
i was waiting in line for it and this
guy comes up to me and i [ __ ] park my
car
on a hill
okay
now what do you do
i don't
i don't want to know what's legal or
what the rules are in that situation
i wanted i want to know how i feel about
it right i
had the car facing
up the hill all right now when the car
is facing up the hill
i gotta go off of feeling right i have
to go off of feeling for which way i
turn the wheel all right i have to do
that now let me tell you why i have to
do that all right because either way
either way i turn
the car wheel either way it's gonna be
fine as long as i turn it okay now if
it's straight and there's no car behind
me whoopsie daisy there's a roller
coaster and a [ __ ] really nice car
it's just gonna just cause it's gonna be
rolling down the [ __ ] street and
people are gonna have to dive out the
way like paper boi right and that's just
facts
where's the cap
okay
so as long as you turn the wheel a
certain way right say this is the
sidewalk and this is the car okay now
this was my car facing up if i turn the
wheel
this way all right what's it do let's
just say the brakes give out
whoopsie-daisy the back hits it right
the backs hit the curve the back hits
the ground now you don't want the back
to hit the curt but whoopsie daisy if it
happens right and also whoopsie daisy if
there's a car
behind it maybe whoopsie daisy hits the
car but everyone's fine though right the
cars get all dented up and smashed but
it's just a fender bender and nobody
dies okay now let's say you
turn the wheels this way right now
whoopsie that's nice whoopsie daisy
nobody gets hurt right whoopsie daisy
it's just the tires that hit it but you
got to be really close you got to be
really [ __ ] close and let's let's
let's all
when you park like this dude and you're
just perpendicular you know you're you
know you don't know if you're close
enough especially if you've got a nice
car anybody's got a nice car so if i do
it like this and i know maybe i'm not
close enough then guess what could
possibly happen whoopsie daisy and we've
got a whole street massacre okay
everyone's got to get hit and i'll lump
the [ __ ] up and die and i might hit two
cars on the way this one and then that
one all right but the law says
and i know this
you got to do it like this okay the law
says you got to do it like this so
whoopsie daisy it's just the tire that's
touching the side of the curb
crisis averted
but i'm thinking more of the what if i
didn't park close enough because i'm
second guessing myself and that's a good
thing right you got to be confident in
your life but when it comes to other
people that you could kill you got to
second guess yourself right
otherwise if you don't and they die you
go oh i was living my life and because
of the way i lived a bunch of people got
ran over all right now just follow me
that's the law but what your boy does is
he decides to go at like do it like this
all right so when the car goes boom
it hits the curb
fine might hit the back the car behind
me all good
i am willing to get a ticket
for that
that thing right there
all right because i will pay if i hit
the guy's back
the front of that car and my car i'll go
through insurance or whatever the [ __ ]
you know
but i think the law should be this way
right
but it's not it's this way
i always park it this way come get me
okay
i'm admitting right now in stereo live
in that ass i go this way come get me
all right so
i do that i get out of my car i walk
over to get in line i'm probably getting
like a full [ __ ] i don't even know
i'm probably just getting literally like
stripped boars meat and i can't remember
but you know i keep it lean right so i'm
getting something super lean and this
guy comes up to me and he says hey man
you parked the wrong way
i'm samaran right but i'm cool right i
breathe i breathe instead of simmer but
i'm still simmering but i'm breathing
too
right and i look at him and i say
what
and the what
even though that's what i said i said
the word
what the context of it and he felt it
was
why would you say that to me
right he felt the you can kind of bend
the word to what you want it's like when
eminem rhymes door hinge with orange you
know what i mean doran's to orange you
got an orange orange right that's what i
do when i'm talking to strangers
that are out of pocket
stranger wants to come up jumping out of
a pocket to me
i could bend my word to me and whatever
the [ __ ] it wants i could say i love you
but in real life you hear get the [ __ ]
out of here
because i've got acting in me corner
you understand all right
so i know how to bend my sentences
to the feeling of the word
dude
okay
do i swear to god if krista was in this
room listening right now she would be
nodding her head back and forth so much
that it would turn around like the
exorcist so
i
say to him what and he says you have to
make it go to where it's
you know pointing the other way so when
it comes down the
the tire just catches the curb and i
don't say anything
because i like for guys to sometimes sit
in what they just said so i just stare
at them and i say after a few beats uh
oh
like that like that like uh oh like a
crunch with my eyes and he goes like
this ah you know i
you probably don't care ab and walks
away dude [ __ ] yeah man that's a ko
[Music]
that's it [ __ ]
you do it dude
that's a k the [ __ ] oh man
that's a ko dude
your boy kills it with them
conversational kos dude come at me which
way am i supposed to park i'll scrunch
up my eyes and say why and you'll leave
all dark
[ __ ] yeah man
oh i love [ __ ] like that man ah you
probably don't care you know what the
best part was i saw him swallow himself
he goes like this ah
and when he goes it was the thing where
it was like he so he says
the thing he says is oh uh you probably
don't care and it was right here when he
did
freeze right there he was like there i
was i realized i was that guy and then
it unfrozen dude he realized he was that
guy
swallowed himself and [ __ ] yeah dude
technical freaking knockout by your boy
johnny keeps it lean
dude we have [ __ ] two we have two now
dude this [ __ ] keeps firing on all
syllables wasn't sure if i was gonna get
in the thick of it started the podcast i
am extremely in the thick of it dude you
guys are here you guys are listening and
i want you to know i [ __ ] love you
dude i love you with my balls and that's
stronger than your heart
[ __ ] yeah dude i love conversational
technical knockouts but it's all good
let's let's cool it down let's relax
dude you know i'm sweating my
[ __ ] ass off dude
one time my friend in uh
when i was in kaaba to college for like
nine months until i decided that until i
realized that nobody needs to go to
college unless you want to be a doctor
alert dude if you're a if you're not
going to be a doctor or a lawyer
what do you do in going to college
somebody's like i have a marketing
degree and i go like this
[Laughter]
oh yeah dude you don't need one and
they're like well yeah you do to get a
good job as a marketer okay well fine
you can get a good job in marketing or
you can build it from the ground up
there's social media now so i'm still
laughing
i'm still laughing marketing guys i'm
still laughing professors
p diddy didn't go to college i think
adam sandler dropped out maybe who knows
but it's like you can do whatever the
[ __ ] you want yeah if you want to be a
lawyer or a doctor or whatever the [ __ ]
nurse
fine
but i was in college for about nine
months until i realized i had acting in
my corner and i dropped out and started
doing stand-up
and uh that was when uh and when i was
in college dude my friend tom he goes
like this you ever get swamp ass and i
was like knew what it was immediately
dude it's the most [ __ ] queen's
[ __ ] you could possibly say as a white
man no doubt you ever get swamp ass
though
eh sir cleans new york
dude i ever get swamp ass though hey
delir you ever get swamp ass knew what
he meant immediately dude that's the
best when you can make up words and know
what people mean and no and they people
know what you mean immediately
because you ever made you ever get swamp
s
and i know it's like it is so human and
as a matter of fact when he said that i
thought about i thought my mind went to
my ass and it was swamp he was just
right you know what i mean
you ever get swamp ass yup
god i used to get so much [ __ ] swamp
ass and when it's humid out forget it
dude
for real
i got it's so [ __ ] humid i swear to
god it's so humid theo vaughn lives down
there it's so [ __ ] ridiculously humid
and and and and it's and it's
unbelievable the the the
like in the it's f you know that's the
other thing too just from louisiana like
when you're in louisiana and it's
[ __ ] hot as [ __ ] and it's august and
it's just so at least like you're
outside and you feel like you're outside
but when you're in new york and it's
humid and there's buildings and [ __ ] and
you're smelling like the side of the
walls because the humidity is just
[ __ ]
like
a gust of stale humid air will just like
waft off of some some outside stucco
painted [ __ ] pizzeria and just tickle
under your nose and you're just like oh
what is that smell and you know it's
trash from like three blocks away and
you're on [ __ ] avenues you're not
even on streets so that's a long way
away
your boy's cultural
he gets it i should write a book but i
won't
you know
um
yeah man
swamp ass [ __ ] arm uh uh you know
swamp pit the [ __ ] pits and [ __ ] dude
forget it man it gets too hot man but
we're not it's the cold days now i hate
the i don't like the the the cold days
are the worst though the [ __ ] hot
days i'll take humid and hot over cold
any day dude my girl's always like put
on if you i'm i'm [ __ ] hot put on a
blanket nah dude
nah
i want to be so [ __ ] blazing hot
above the [ __ ] i've talked about this
above the bed above the covers i don't
go with the that's bit [ __ ] i don't put
the covers over me to do my own
temperature i figure out the temperature
and i lay the [ __ ] down over the bed
because that's how a real [ __ ]
g sleeps dude
sleep oh yeah oh the middle of the night
oh oh oh
you can tell me a story
[Laughter]
bro get the [ __ ] sheets out of here
sleeping on the bed like a goddamn mummy
that's how i do it
anyway
um
ah
whatever dude
[Music]
hey guys i want to talk to you about a
little thing called ship station um
it's great okay the holidays are the
most wonderful time of the year we can
all agree on that but if you're running
an online store they can also be the
craziest time of year and the most
stressful time of year you've got
inventory to manage orders to fill and a
growing list of stressed out customers
checking in twice a day wondering
whether those last minute gifts are
going to arrive in time well listen with
shipstation the hassle of shipping out
holiday orders completely melts away
leaving you with happier customers and
more freedom to run your business or
even better enjoy your much needed time
off
my merch store
absolutely crushes it using using ship
station um it uh
you know you can go ahead and ask the
fans they get their stuff fast uh even
this one right here the the sorry strong
guys one we
got the orders and put it out
immediately the next day um they're
great um if you sell anything online uh
i don't need to tell you that shipping
can be super frustrating you get it
there are so many carriers and a ton of
factors that go into figuring out the
best rate for each order
uh more people are shopping online every
single year year by year and shipstation
makes shipping
the easy part of running your online
store oh by the way 98
of companies that use shipstation for a
year keep using it for as long as
they're in business
so
it's that good you do the math
make this holiday season a little bright
make this holiday season a little
brighter with shipstation use my offer
code congrats to get a 60 day free trial
that's just enough time to handle this
holiday rush
go to
shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top and
enter code congrats ship station make
ship happen
[Music]
meta
they changed finally facebook changed
with that [ __ ] ass facebook
facebook isn't the name for a company
meta nah that's a name for a company
dude that's such a good name people are
always hating on everything facebook's
doing fine hate on the [ __ ]
misinformation that they did the
propaganda the [ __ ] okay fine but
you know what you did right facebook
renamed your [ __ ] to a good thing meta
is cool you know why because you started
the metaverse dude you started that as a
company and now it's gonna be a thing
that's [ __ ] amazing your boy sees the
commodity in that and now guess what i'm
not on facebook i mean i have a fan page
on there but right now your boy's gonna
have to start to get [ __ ] facebook
again
because meta
that's the [ __ ] also a meta world peace
somewhere punching the air for real just
like god damn it this [ __ ] worked for 10
years
what's his name steve not [ __ ] what's
his name mark zuckerberg just like yeah
in the corner unplugging itself meta
world peace joke is on you ya ya ya ya
about the fact that the facebook or meta
headquarters are one hacker way
supposing yourself
hacker one hacker
[Laughter]
oh man
did they mean to do that they had to
dude
[ __ ] them but that's all good dude your
metadata
they got the infinite loop the infinity
loop
or how the [ __ ] it is that's what's up
meta dude taking over the world salute
take it over
guarantee i would be so [ __ ] evil if
i went to go dude if i created some [ __ ]
like fake but let me tell you something
man mark zuckerberg has no personality
we all know that and it's cuz he plugs
himself in at night he's a goddamn robot
and that's fine
but he you know he's either a robot that
looks like a human or a human that looks
like a robot either way he's taking over
the world bro thank your lucky stars
it's not me and that's in that situation
oh bro forget that man i'd wear capes
i'd fire guns everywhere i'd be in an
arby's firing guns up and then they'd
arrest me but i'd be like what can you
do i have all the money
um
yeah dude
amazing that they did they just changed
your name and people are just up in arms
so mad at all the [ __ ] they're gonna
come out and they're gonna survive talk
about survivors dude that song by
destiny child is literally about [ __ ]
meta
amma
um
yeah yeah that's how mark zuckerberg
laughs for real
meets meets i love meat
i love meats joke is on you
meta
um
i don't know
i don't even know does mark zuckerberg
he's so smart though he has to be so
smart right so it's like but i almost
want to be like give him the benefit of
the doubt and be like does he really
know what the [ __ ] he's doing or is he
truly an evil genius like because that's
the other thing i don't believe in in an
evil i don't believe in that when people
say like oh he's a monster he's this
he's that people like you don't get it
dude
this person grew up a different way than
you okay
you don't understand like dude the
people the way people lived in the in
the 1600s they were lopping each other's
heads off
for like believing in witches
if anyone did that now they'd
immediately get incarcerated right there
would even be a trial they'd be like
lock him up he locked off somebody for
believing something right but that you
don't know how you would be back in 1620
because you didn't grow up in 1620 and
that goes for people who are from you
know los angeles and then there's people
from st louis and then there's people
from vancouver there's people from india
dude there's people from uh botswana
there's people from iran you don't know
what the [ __ ] these people's lives were
like so you're like oh yeah they're
barbarians they're monsters they're you
don't know you don't know how you would
fare i i'll tell you what if i grew up
anywhere where there's like no
running water
that's it for me
immediate warlord
war criminal warlord
warlord i don't even know if there are
warlords anymore
i am the warlord
dude if dysentery what's the dysentery
that's the thing you get when you drink
the water and the worms are in it and
you got a [ __ ] everywhere diarrhea
disenter whatever the [ __ ] dude if
that's anywhere near me immediate
warlord
you understand how good you got it these
[ __ ] are living in america
but but uh what's it called uh you don't
know but america has the [ __ ]
projects america's got [ __ ] where
there's no running water and i'm not
saying that that's what happened to
what's his name [ __ ] mark zuckerberg
but my point is you don't that's the
extreme version you don't know how
somebody grew up you don't know if
somebody grew up and were whipped every
day by their parents you don't know and
people don't tell you they don't meet
you and say hi hello i was whipped every
day by my parents and you say oh well
that's why you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
you stole my parking space you don't do
that right
you literally just sit and you think
well that person's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
because of the way that they are and the
way that
it's not about what happened to them
that's that's one of the things it's
like when you
when something happens to you
and it's unjust or shitty you think hey
[ __ ] that thing that happened to me
but if you see someone else act a
certain way that you might even act
you don't think hey i wonder what
happened to that guy you think that
person's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and that is incongruous
think about that for everyone dude i got
some empathy going on man what can i say
i'm an empath
what can i say man
if i grew up a place with dysentery is
that what it's called
i [ __ ] i'm a warlord immediate by
nine years old
la plus hud off that's me and a diaper
with just a shirt on they probably don't
even make shirts wherever i am just a
diaper they probably don't have diapers
i just got someone else's hat that i
locked their head off stole their hat
and i piss and [ __ ] in their hat and i
tape it around my [ __ ] my baby bum
lap his head off
i'm angry as [ __ ] by nine
you understand
cause you don't know me
if dysentery's around and i'm brought up
are you following me at all does this
make any sense
producers aren't even saying anything
welcome all in my shoes that's where
that comes from
nobody gives a [ __ ] about that nowadays
they just want to [ __ ] they want to
castrate chris pratt for what he [ __ ]
said about his beautiful wife on
instagram right
did you see about this [ __ ]
chris pratt
pratt
uh well let me just go chris with pratt
here we go let me google it here's the
news
i'll just go to news chris pratt's a
good guy okay
chris price slammed online for posts
about catherine schwarzenegger lost
respect for you
this is what he writes
shared a photo of himself and his wife
wrapping their arms around one another
schwarzenegger 31 gays lovingly this is
from [ __ ] some website fox i think
news well i don't know uh guys this is
what he says guys for real look how
she's looking at me
hey i don't want to buy wine click off
this [ __ ] banner guys for real look
how she's looking at me i mean find you
somebody that looks at you like that you
know he captioned the photo we met in
church she's given me an amazing life a
gorgeous healthy daughter
to chew so loudly that sometimes i put
my earbuds to drown it out but that's
love that's what he said
pratt then joked about while his wife
helps him with everything he returns the
favor periodically by opening a jar of
pickles
that's the trade he added her heart is
pure and it belongs to me my greatest
treasure right next to my ken griffey jr
upper deck rookie card which if you know
is
you know it's saying a lot uh he
continued it's her birthday in about six
weeks so if i don't get anything i'll
tell her to look back on this post love
you honey
cool
obviously joking
obviously [ __ ] joking somebody says
you do know you have a son right said a
follower in reference to prat's
nine-year-old son jack whom he shares
his with ex-wife anna faris should he
also be a greatest treasure
and someone else says for me if the was
the emphasis it was an emphasis oh for
me it was the emphasis
emphasis emphasis on healthy child like
your firstborn is lesser in your eyes
suggested a comment commenter you need
to go read that sentence through his
eyes and apologize to him because your
wording was cruel dude
someone else says wait you might not get
or anything another ass
while the third posed if you don't get
or anything
met in church but you left your first
wife for her so i wouldn't call you mr
holy
you open a jar of pickles her heart
belongs to you
someone says what the hell happened to
you man
this is great i really don't think this
is as great of a post as you think it is
warned another
yeah lost respect for you in this post
for multiple reasons sad
hey guys
you're [ __ ] losers
look pratt whose reps did not
immediately respond to fox's news
request yeah no [ __ ]
stop wasting [ __ ] time
it's so ridiculous
how hilarious
and [ __ ] god anybody who comments on
anything i comment on [ __ ] all the time
but you're just like it's like i gotta
stop
how is this something
dude and this is fox news
mainstream media dude huh
any media really honestly
not even just mainstream media anybody
who's like i'll figure it out you don't
know
oh [ __ ] i'm gonna go slip into something
a little more comfortable i'm hot
i'll be right back
[Music]
and we're back there that's much better
i had to put on the [ __ ] something
that's a little bit more comfortable
with loving it
look at that beautiful the lettering
pops
um yeah so
dude
papa john's
i don't know if he's trying to stay in
the news or what
but he said
dude this is so
unbelievable okay papa john's said
that he has eaten
800 pizzas in 18 months
800 pizzas in 18 months okay
that's
[ __ ]
so many pizzas
that's way more than i've had over 40
pizzas in the last 30 days
living currently
in march
dude that's so
many pizzas
no i have that many pieces he said he
wanted to make sure that the quality of
the pizzas
still held up since he was fired for
saying the n-word
the whole thing is so 2001 it's
unbelievable first of all dude
you're going against the art your own
argument but the fact i want to see if
the quality is still up to par hey dude
if you ate 800 pizza in 18 months
the quality is fine because
you're alive
okay
you're an alive person still the
quality's fine dude that's 44 pizzas
what is it 44 pizzas a month
pizzas a month i think it's far i think
i did the math it's 44 pizzas a month
it's 6
400 slices of pizza
dude 44 pizzas a month that's one and a
half pizzas a day dude if i eat three
pizzas
period in any amount of time
in [ __ ] three weeks
i feel like i'm going to die
and papa johnson was 60
800 pizzas in eight also you didn't
i want to know how much he's lying that
that's what i want to know i i want to
know
him he he might have eaten zero pizzas
because i'll cry if you're saying you
you've eaten 800 pizzas in eight uh in
18 months you you're of course lying so
why wouldn't you lie all the way
he's gangster though as a kid i realized
that if you lie and you pick the
craziest lie people will believe it
because why the [ __ ] would you lie that
crazy but this still f this this is
beyond that like i remember one time
this uh my buddy called to ask if i
wanted to hang out i didn't like the guy
and i was like in eighth grade and i was
like i don't know how to respond so i
was like sorry man i gotta go to the
opera i was in eighth
grade he was like chris you want to hang
out i was like okay i can't get out of
it man my mom and dad are taking me to
the opera
never went to the opera that's what came
out though
and what's he going to do what was he
going to know you if i said oh i can't
because i'm grounded he'd find out
the opera
he'll just leave it alone
he'll leave it alone david lim would
leave it alone that was his name
i think it was david chen actually can't
remember racist um
yeah dude anyway didn't eat 800 why is
this and then it's news dude
oh
and this is the next [ __ ] thing below
it disgraced piece of mogul papa john
this i i don't like when they call
people disgraced
i don't like when they call people
disgraced because that's up to the
person
that is completely
up to the person to me you can't call me
disgraced
because i i'm cool i'm chilling dude you
know papa john's is like chilling with
[ __ ] crazy statues in his house
he's not descri that's up to him
this [ __ ] guy's still making news
disgrace to what he's eating [ __ ] 800
pizzas in 18 months dude you think that
sounds like a disgrace guy no way that's
king [ __ ] dude that is king [ __ ]
just only eating pizzas with toppings by
the way dude with toppings that's like
doubling it up i mean if you eat a meat
lover's pizza half of the time
of those eight i just 400 meals even if
you eat ten meat lovers pizza that
[ __ ] stacks up this guy's gonna blow
the [ __ ] up he's gonna look like a dick
tracy character soon this great pizza
mogul papa john thinks
uh
thinks the sculpture in his mansion of
two eagles humping is badass of course
it does
there's i have never read a surprising
headline about papa john's any guy that
would have two gold eagles
sculpted
humping in your house
of course would use the term to describe
it badass
also
every other [ __ ] thing i see this guy
god this guy looks like the [ __ ]
god this guy looks like the guy that
would that would like like that i'd know
in high school that dated like the
[ __ ] trashy girl
40 pizzas and 800 pizzas 18 months
also
why are you counting how many pizzas
you're eating
after 12 don't you lose track also if
you're eating 800 pizzas to try and
confirm the quality of papa john's
why don't you know after three pizzas
oh
oh what
[Laughter]
what number did you get to 800 was the
one where he's like you know what i got
it i figured it out dude it's not it's
actually it's not up to par
800 later
dude stop after a few bites of one slice
dave portnoy's got that one bite test he
just goes in comes out yeah i got a
pizza yeah [ __ ] it um yeah it's all
right that's it that's the whole show
papa john's is trying to do a [ __ ]
document series about this goddamn [ __ ]
pizzas
in 18 months
papa john schnatter
isn't that his last name schnatter
wow
papa john and [ __ ] aaron rodgers
together i'm telling you right now
could launch the biggest crypto [ __ ]
it's unbelievable
they they could literally launch the
biggest crypto [ __ ] it would be like a
[ __ ]
um
a gif like a [ __ ] thing that didn't
even turn that much like a pizza that
was just holographic and [ __ ] and it
would be getting injected with a [ __ ]
coronavirus [ __ ] that [ __ ] i'm telling
you right now if they did that they'd be
[ __ ] minted they already are minted
but they'd be [ __ ] minted dude
this guy's obsessed with the quality of
the got fire dude he's an evil villain
papa john schneider's an evil villain he
was fired at like what 50 years old and
is obsessed with papa john's still dude
if you fire me i'm gone
i'm gone i'll never do i'll never be
around the thing again
i got kind of cut out of that movie i
didn't watch it i'm gone dude see ya
i'm not sitting watching it night after
night could have been me eating [ __ ]
40 pizzas in 30 days
you cut your boy out
i'm gone
i'm not a part of it dude
he's an evil villain i'll show these
[ __ ] i'll keep eating their
pizzas and i'll eat so many pizzas that
i will eventually either be taking them
down or ruling their company once again
and every time i see papa john's in a
[ __ ] news article he's always wearing
a [ __ ] red button down hey papa john
stop wearing that huh
even if it's not the outfit
don't reminisce with
this guy's lost his mind dude this guy's
gonna take he could launch the biggest
crypto with aaron rodgers dude
what are you doing i need to do it i
need to get on that nft game dude
i need to get on nft
dude just sell my [ __ ] [ __ ] and balls
holograph holographic [ __ ] and balls
moving back and through the nfts are so
stupid
and if these are so [ __ ] stupid and
every dj in the game is like all right
check it out got an nft now you could in
you could buy five seconds of me music
and own it
how much is it
4 million point five
that [ __ ] beeble crap guy who's the
only guy who did it right you know and
then everyone else is trying to [ __ ]
duplicate what beeblecrap did
beetlecrap
[Laughter]
dude
beeplecrap is the killingest artist dude
i love beeplecrap that's his name right
dude peoplecrap the name alone
i wish i named my son beeplecrap dude
beeplecrap dalia wow that would be the
dude
jim here
nancy here jill here beeplecrap
just in the back just
now
grew up so [ __ ] up because his name is
beeplecrap wow dude i love that like
i'll be playing [ __ ] on twitch and
some guy just named like [ __ ] harry
jen will like comment on something
speaking of twitch i was playing [ __ ]
red dead redemption 2 the other day and
i was [ __ ] murdering horses and um i
was
i actually i wasn't murdering horses i
learned my lesson i got my honor up dude
my honor went crazy good and i started
dreaming of deer and um
the character in the game starts
dreaming of deer if you do good deeds
and if you don't do good deeds he dreams
of wolves i started dreaming of wolves
and i was like whoa those are scary
dreams and somebody in the chat was like
yeah well you dream of deer if you get
your honor up and from then on dude i
started saying howdy to everybody i
walked by and got my honor up real nice
i did side missions i returned babies to
ladies and i did all sorts of good stuff
so i brought my honor up i brought it
way up dude and uh i brought it up so
much that
the game changed
you know
it was actually weird i was playing this
game red dead redemption
i've never played this game before and
i've read no spoilers
but i was playing the game and you're
this character named arthur morgan
and he sounds like this you know he's a
real rough hardcore [ __ ]
country
gunslinger right
um
and you can be any kind of guy that you
want
in this game it's an open world video
game you can go and you can literally
stab everybody murder horses kill
rabbits and not even pick up their pelt
for [ __ ]
to sell right you can just go on a
murdering spree but it brings your honor
way down
and that's what i did in the beginning
of the game because i thought it was fun
i lived
i lived for
arthur morgan
i was self-centered the beginning of
that red dead redemption game i was
doing that and then i realized halfway
through i started dreaming of wolves
like i mentioned i started dreaming of
wolves and somebody in the chat said you
know what if you get your honor up
you start dreaming of deer and i was
like well that's interesting
i was like well why would i [ __ ]
why would i get my honor up and half the
people in the chat were like it's not
that fun if you play with your honor up
and some people are like it's actually
cool because the ending is better
so it's like whatever
so i started feeling like you know what
i want to take this game seriously i
mean totally [ __ ] dork [ __ ] like it's
actually more fun if you seriously take
this game and actually play it for for
real uh it's actually much more fun and
it actually it makes you feel a lot
better at the end you get the better
ending so i'm playing this game it just
makes me laugh people go out there and
just stabbing horses for no reason i
just don't see what it benefits what
does it examine in the human race so um
i'm playing the game and i start to
change my honor i'm saying how did
everybody on the streets like i
mentioned i start [ __ ] doing side
missions i start getting my honor up my
honor get so some people are now joining
on the twitch again and they're like
whoa you got your honor way up what the
[ __ ] going on so in the middle of the
game somebody coughs on you you don't
think much of it it's actually more in
the beginning of the game somebody
coughs on you you're going to bully him
for money that he owes you and he coughs
on you you don't even think of much much
of it at all
there comes a time in the moment in the
game where you just faint and you fall
down and then the doctor says hey guess
what you have tuberculosis now back then
tuberculosis was a death sentence in the
1800s this game takes place it was a
death sentence so you're gonna die in
this game now i'm like well dude i gotta
win the game before i die
as the game goes on arthur morgan keeps
coughing more and more he's just
coughing more and more he keeps coughing
i'm like this [ __ ] sucks my character
just keeps [ __ ] coughing it sucks and
in a way it was like now i'm playing
with this character and i've got the
disease and i just want to fight these
[ __ ] but he keeps stopping and
coughing and [ __ ] and i realize
because one of the guys in the chat on
twitch says you know how you got
tuberculosis and i said how he said
cause that guy coughed on you i said is
there any way to avoid it and he said
nah it's part of the narrative of the
game
so i realized it was predestined that
this character
was gonna die
and i've already got my honor good
i went from a derelict
to a good person in this game and i was
gonna [ __ ] die anyway
so i get upset
i get upset at the game
you know i'm a bit of a nihilist myself
but arthur morgan
it's not even me so i'm playing this
game and i don't even get to be the
supernaturalist i want to be in this
virtual game
so i look at the save
point you know you could save and when
you save the game
it tells you how much of the game
you're completed
and i'm at about 60
and arthur is [ __ ] dying
all right
and i'm like how bad does it get because
you can't cure tuberculosis what happens
well all of your friends in the game red
dead redemption they backstab you
and you're on the run and you're running
from the cops and the people who are
supposed to save you and back you up
they [ __ ] backstab you they sell you
out and you end up
getting shot at
stumbling over rocks and it's not
looking good for arthur morgan aka me
so one of the other homies in my posse
comes up and he's always been a good guy
in the game
and he
says you doing all right and arthur
morgan me says
you know what
i'm not gonna make it i'll hold them off
while you get away and the guy
says
i can't do that jim mar mars marsden jim
marsden i think whatever the [ __ ] i
still don't really know um but he was
like
uh
i'm not gonna let you do that and arthur
says
it would make me happy if you let me
save you and you go right so he gives
him the satchel that arthur morgan has
to jim and he gives him his guns and he
takes his hat off and he puts his hat on
jim
and arthur says leave me here
and you're basically just arthur morgan
now no satchel which by the way has all
my [ __ ] that i've collected in the game
throughout the game it has
in his satchel right
i gave it away to some [ __ ] [ __ ]
side character and now i don't have it
anymore and i got to fight off this
[ __ ] these bad guys which are
actually the you know the [ __ ] the
cops
and so he's shooting he's shooting these
[ __ ] and uh
there's no
no way out of it
you fall on a rock and you start
breathing and you breathe your last
breath
and
arthur morgan dies and i realize
now there's 60 percent of the game left
and there's nothing i could have done
but he died and he died and he was
dreaming of deer the whole time he
turned it around and he redeemed himself
into a good person and i got the good
ending but there's still 60 percent of
the game left and i realized that when
arthur morgan
says
hey you know
get out of here
you now become
this other character for the rest of the
35 of the game all right
and it's [ __ ] emotional dude
it's like emotional it's not like a
video game like tecmo bowl where they're
like
right
it's emotional like the music happens
and it's a beautiful song not even just
score it's somebody singing like it was
a beautiful it's like you they have
youtube on it or some [ __ ] and i'm just
like this isn't even like the rest of
the game at all this is beautiful the
sun's peeking out over as arthur
morgan's taking his last breath and in
this moment
calvin walks in
and calvin goes to climb up on my chair
and as he goes to climb up on my chair
he falls and hits his head
and just starts wailing because he hurt
he hurt himself and he i said oh no
buddy and i pick him up
and i'm watching [ __ ] arthur morgan
or somebody [ __ ]
maybe i'm the new guy now and i'm riding
into the sunset and the music's blaring
and i'm calvin
is crying and i say it's okay buddy
everyone falls down
but the worst part is over
and now
you can move on from that and with the
music and calvin's crying and now i'm
crying because i'm telling calvin
something that's
you know like personal to me and i'm
living this [ __ ] to i used to be arthur
morgan and now i'm this other [ __ ]
dude it was so [ __ ] hilarious dude
i'm sitting there crying with calvin
calvin bumped his head but we were both
getting through it dude
and it was beautiful in a way you know
it was really nice that it was really
beautiful it was hilarious
um
i don't know it was so [ __ ] funny
dude
he hit his [ __ ] head and i gotta give
him a pep talk while i'm crying
in this goddamn video game
i don't know
what was the thing we were just talking
about about how
oh yeah thanksgiving coming up
my friend never celebrates thanksgiving
because he was like [ __ ] that dude i
just eat pizza this is what he says he's
like i eat pizza because [ __ ] all
these people slaughtered the indians and
that's not cool and everyone's like well
yeah but you know what
um
it's actually thanksgiving was a time
where uh
they
they came up onto the
i know america where they discovered
america and they acted like they were uh
friendly with them and they broke bread
with them and [ __ ] and had a meal and
that's what thanksgiving is like they
were saying that it's better and i was
like that's worse than just [ __ ]
slaughtering them and he was like no
it's better to be friends with someone
at least act like your friends and i was
like no that's [ __ ] worse dude if
someone's gonna slaughter you you just
just slaughter me dude don't act like
you're my friend
don't [ __ ] just kill me dude
don't hide how you're doing me to death
that's the worst
all right i want to talk about something
else here this is just a beautiful thing
that um a fan made rob hay from uh
congratulations he's a member of the
patreon and all that [ __ ] but he sent me
this first of all he made me this
[ __ ] bag that's like a take of the of
the
nike sign and it says life rips which is
awesome i don't know how he even [ __ ]
made it but
this [ __ ] is crazy
he made these
congratulations
jordan
ones and he made these he like painted
them it's got the
the logo in the back of the insignia and
then it says life rips on the tongue i
mean he [ __ ] made these he painted
these i mean he's got a pacifier on the
thing like for the babies and it's
unbelievable he even got the the the
off-white tag on it that he put on here
and it says uh life rips care of nike
congratulations
it's just
hilarious
and i reached out to them i was like how
the [ __ ]
one of the girls on the on the patreon
was like yeah rob took a long time to
make him he did it himself i don't know
how the [ __ ]
you make [ __ ] like this is his first try
how do you do this
unbelievable but these are going on i'm
not wearing these there's no way these
are i'm gonna either put them
somewhere or have them i got to have
them at least on the desk but these are
amazing and i wanted to thank rob haye
for that this is just awesome
um
and he sent them to me and i love them
dude um i'll try them on once for good
measure but i'm not getting those dirty
um so that's it
uh i enjoy talking to you guys every
week um you're my church in a way and uh
you know that's that but thanks very
much for listening and i hope you had a
good time okay bye hey guys that's the
episode for this week on youtube if you
want to catch the rest of the episode go
on patreon.com full episodes we have
full episodes with no commercials on
audio or youtube on our patreon for just
six bucks a month patreon.com
uh
crystalia and also it's uh we've got a
backload of episodes that aren't even
accessible to you guys uh unless you're
on patreon uh about you know we got
about six or seven or eight or nine
episodes on there now um that you can
listen to right now if you unlock it the
patreon for six bucks a month uh thanks
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
okay
i'm sweaty